hey everyone welcome to the gridiron  heights Christmas party keep my layoffs  are coming  oh no I'm freaking out no no I'm not  being replaced I'm still hurt see Santa  Cruden I'm gaming all my players away  okay and then I'm re for you whoa hey  you want your car hey how about you Dan  Schneider man you owe me 125 million  dollars oh can i Jerri please okay oh no  this is a work event behave yourself  that's a fine yeah well we'll see Kyle  find you - thank you just give me get my  stuff you're having a party without me  I'm having the time of my life  Oh dad for this  okay the NFC's a mess no I'm going  four-wheel you guys don't go to bed stay  down I'm calm I can run oh why are these  kids so mobile  [Music]  so slow this channel watch wiper sauce I  gotta go